well how's this for a greeting welcome
to hell you just met the devil and
that's the friendly version from shark
tank's Kevin O'Leary
you know the one with a big mouth big
opinions and very big success so is the
only way to get ahead by leaving a trail
of blood in the water i sat down with
mr. wonderful to find out there's a
reason people scream when they see a
shark it's the fear of the bite for pigs
pigs get slaughtered
next guy's gonna walk in here and get my
money and he'll get rich but not you
take the money you crazy chickens on
Shark Tank
Kevin O'Leary is the bully in the
proverbial black hat it fits him to a
tee and he knows it what you see is what
you get I've forgotten about the sky
already bring on the next deal I'm here
to make money
well people say I mean but I I really
believe this I tell the truth
I really tell the truth yeah you tell it
but you tell it brutally well what do
you think happens in the real world if
you think I'm tough I'm boot camp for
the war they're going to go into when
they try and run a business but do you
have to be so mean about it I've got a
bad rap for that I couldn't care less
O'Leary has two things most people don't
a ton of money and a desire to bankroll
the dreams of entrepreneurs people like
Jeff Cohen who dove into the shark tank
peddling a guitar with a collapsible
neck they fold in half Kevin seems to be
a guy that doesn't like to lose when he
decides he wants something bring it over
here
he wants it but he didn't get it Cohen
felt Kevin's proposal came with too many
strings attached
I don't accept the deal is on the table
you're dead to me
when you say no to my diya you're dead
in typical o'leary fashion
there was no goodbye hug that is a human
tragedy and teaching the son that it's a
crime you should be arrested
you can't help as you watch Kevin
O'Leary on shark tank and wonder is this
all an act this bullying it's not an act
and I think of myself as the merchant of
truth
I really do outside the tank the 58 year
old is the man behind O'Leary funds a
billion dollar mutual fund company
morning Gus do you treat your employees
and speak to your employees the way you
treat the contestants on Shark Tank um
yes sometimes really yeah for me
business is war I want to take prisoners
I want to destroy my enemies my
competitors don't ever walk in front of
me unprepared don't ever get in front of
me without your numbers never bring a
half-baked proposition and waste my time
but that caesarian leadership style rubs
some people the wrong way there's even a
word for it O'Leary says it's okay if
you don't like a CEO where the decisions
he or she makes because they are not
here to please you respect and Trust are
the backbone of a business not
likability every bully has a bully and
O'Leary met his years ago I work for
Steve Jobs and if you think I'm tough
you should have met him
really oh my goodness he rated me in a
boardroom once in front of my own
employees he was vicious like worse than
you unsure I am a nothing burger
compared to what he was but the roots of
O'Leary's management style run deeper
back to childhood memories of his father
a failed salesman he died when he was 37
years old 37 a robot a broke alcoholic
alone in an apartment that's what
happened to him before his father died
O'Leary says his parents were in a
dysfunctional marriage so much so his
mother took him and his brother and fled
to Europe
only seven years old at the time O'Leary
remembers it like it was yesterday
I remember being in Oslo one night and
she completely broke down I mean just
because she was running out of money she
was in total fear and I could sense it I
said to myself wow this is bad I can't
let this happen to me I just intuitively
heard her DNA pass to me on that fear
and I changed me forever years later her
fortunes would change and she would loan
her son ten thousand dollars for the
software business he would later sell
for billions many people have tried to
figure out what I'm worth
I have enough to get by I'm okay Leary
has all the toys that come with success
the cars the private jets even a secret
location that stores a private wine
collection as massive as his ego this is
what a million dollars in wine looks
like no surprise that includes his very
own labels that is nectar from the
nipple of Aphrodite just another taste
of the good life where the man they call
mr. wonderful a life that includes Linda
his wife of more than 20 years and their
two kids both of whom will have to make
it on their own because dad isn't
sharing the wealth like nothing nothing
I'll pay their entire way right through
the end of their education as far as
they want to take it but when that's
over it's over and good luck so if your
daughter calls you up and says daddy you
know I'm in terrible trouble
you know I desperately need some money
the answer's no go fix it go figure it
out figuring it out is what O'Leary does
best
remember the collapsible guitar deal
that collapsed well negotiations
continued behind the scenes and the two
sides are now in perfect harmony
I love guitars I knew that was going to
be a hit I knew it I knew it I knew it I
just had to get a piece of it you know
when you really want it when you really
feel it and you know viscerally it
next listen to your God by that's what I
said
[Music]